Sospecho que tal vez ya estén familiarizados
con el término mezcla; realmente significa
lo que crees que significa. Si tomamos dos
o más sustancias y las mezclamos estamos
hablando de una mezcla, y podría ser un sólido,
un líquido o un gas. Ahora, fundamentalmente hay
dos tipos diferentes de mezclas: hay mezclas
heterogéneas. Y vamos a encontrarnos muchas
veces con este prefijo "hetero" que significa
diferente, heterogéneo. Se refiere a mezclas que,
vistas desde un punto de vista macro... Haré
una mezcla líquida heterogénea. A menudo pienso
que en una forma extrema, a simple vista podemos
ver que diferentes partes de las mezclas tienen
diferentes concentraciones de las cosas que se
han mezclado. Un ejemplo en el que generalmente
pienso es la leche con chocolate. Esto no está
bien mezclado, en la parte superior vamos a ver
estos grumos y, dependiendo de hacia donde
miremos, realmente podemos ver que no hay
concentraciones consistentes de las diferentes
sustancias. Las propiedades de las mezclas
son diferentes dependiendo de qué parte de la
mezcla miremos. Ahora podemos imaginar que si
hay mezclas heterogéneas, lo contrario serían
mezclas homogéneas, éstas serían mezclas que,
cuando las miramos desde un punto de vista macro,
cualquier punto de la mezcla parece consistente:
mezclas homogéneas. Hay otro término para las
mezclas homogéneas que probablemente hayas
escuchado, también se conocen como soluciones. Y
como mencioné cuando hablamos de mezclas podríamos
estar hablando de sólido, líquido o gas. A menudo
pensamos en líquido de inmediato, pero puede ser
sólido, líquido o gaseoso; y lo mismo ocurre
con las soluciones, podemos tener sólidos,
líquidos o gases. Un ejemplo de una solución
sólida sería, digamos, una aleación de metal,
donde a nivel macro vemos el color. ¿Qué tan bien
conduce la electricidad?, ¿qué tan maleable es?,
¿qué tan duro es? Parece que las propiedades
son uniformes en toda la aleación. Si tenemos
algún tipo de aleación de metal, si viéramos así,
digamos, el bronce, bueno, desde mi punto de vista
todo el bronce tiene las mismas propiedades, pero
si tuviéramos que mirarlo con un microscopio muy
sensible o con base en los modelos con los que
ahora sabemos lo que está pasando en ese metal,
en esa aleación, lo que está sucediendo es que
en realidad tenemos una mezcla de metales. Pero
es una mezcla homogénea de metales porque a nivel
macro realmente no podemos ver las diferencias;
ahora a un nivel micro sí podemos, porque hay
diferentes metales mezclados en esta aleación.
Como podemos imaginar también tenemos soluciones
líquidas, y en Química nos ocuparemos más de
éstas, también nos ocuparemos de soluciones
sólidas y gaseosas. Y cuando pienso en una
mezcla líquida homogénea o una solución líquida,
la que me viene a la mente -aunque veremos muchas
de éstas en nuestro viaje por la Química- es el
agua salada, agua salada. El agua salada tiene
cloruro de sodio disuelto en agua, y si fuéramos
al océano y tuviéramos que mirar el agua salada
o si midiéramos sus propiedades incluso en un
laboratorio, veríamos que las propiedades en
toda el agua salada parecen ser uniformes, a nivel
macro parece ser homogénea, parece uniforme. Pero
si miramos lo que está pasando a nivel atómico,
veríamos que tenemos moléculas de agua. Déjenme
dibujar el agua de esta manera. Este es el oxígeno
y cada uno tiene 2 hidrógenos, y este extremo es
parcialmente positivo, hemos visto esto varias
veces, el extremo del hidrógeno El extremo del
oxígeno es parcialmente negativo, entonces, cuando
disuelves el cloruro de sodio, los aniones cloruro
se sienten atraídos por los extremos positivos
del agua, de modo que tal vez tengamos un anión
cloruro allí, y los iones de sodio serían atraídos
por el extremo negativo del H₂O, así que ese es
el sodio. De modo que cuando lo miramos desde
una perspectiva micro, vemos que hay diferentes
moléculas, pero en una perspectiva macro, sus
propiedades macro como ¿qué tan bien responden
a diferentes estímulos?, ¿qué tan bien conducen
la electricidad?, ¿qué aspecto tiene?, parecen
ser uniformes. Ahora, para ser claros: el agua
salada no es la única solución líquida, hay muchos
tipos de soluciones líquidas. En Química a menudo
veremos que el agua es nuestro solvente más común,
solvente es lo que hay en mayor abundancia, en
donde se están disolviendo otras cosas. Las cosas
que se están disolviendo se llaman soluto. En
este caso es el cloruro de sodio y el agua es el
solvente. Déjenme escribir esto: solvente. Cuando
tenemos una solución en la que algo está disuelto
en agua, a menudo se le denomina solución acuosa,
y a veces se abrevia aq o ac. Ahora, por último
pero no menos importante, tenemos los gases. Y
seguro que podemos tener una solución de gas,
la más común es la que tú y yo estamos respirando
ahora mismo, el aire que nos rodea es una solución
gaseosa. Sus propiedades microscópicas parecen
consistentes, parecen uniformes, pero sabemos que
el gas que nos rodea es una mezcla de nitrógeno,
oxígeno, dióxido de carbono así como moléculas de
otras cosas; de modo que un buen ejemplo de una
solución gaseosa sería el aire. Ahí lo vamos a
dejar. Esto es una buena introducción a lo que es
una mezcla, los tipos de mezclas y especialmente
el subtipo de una mezcla que es una mezcla
homogénea, que a menudo llamamos una solución.